- So you're on Only
Murders in the Building.
- Yes.
- I love this
with Steve Martin and Martin Short.
(audience cheering)
So it's so good.
So what's it been like working with them?
It's such an odd,
like pairing, yeah.
- It's so odd.
It's so weird.
You know,
my whole day consists of
listening to 70 year olds
talk about news or who's
like or Steve was like,
who's a Dua Lipa?
And I was like, no, it's not a thing.
It's a and and they're just
so much fun to be around.
They're hilarious, they're pure
and they're professional and they just,
they keep me wanting to be better.
- Oh, that's cool.
- Yes.
- Ain't it cool how life works like that.
You didn't think you'd be doing something
and then all of a sudden
you're doing this show
and you're surrounded by people
you never would've thought
you'd be surrounded by.
- Never.
- And it kind of brings out
the best version of you.
- Definitely.
- That's the people who
we should surround ourself with.
- That's right.
- Yep.
- I'd rather hang out
with them.
- Yeah, it's hard.
Well, it's nice too 'cause
they've been here for a minute.
- Yeah.
- So sometimes it's nice
to just shut up and listen and be like,
what can you teach me
'cause I'll take it, yeah.
- Yeah, definitely,
definitely.
- I love that.